carla beauvais et robert d'automne
bonsoir à vous deux le premier ministre
pense que c'est l'anxiété économique qui
a incité en partie la moitié des
américains à voter pour donald trump
carla est ce qu'ils les raisons selon
vous tout à fait je pense qu'une partie
de la population qui est très anxieuse
par rapport à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de notre shop pendant les
débats il a été très convaincant pour
discréditer byden sur la question du
fracking sur l'industrie pétrolière
aussi donc je pense que oui à l'anxiété
mais aussi il faut pas oublier que la
présidence de chant pas été marqués
vraiment sur la division sur les
tensions raciales et ça aussi je pense
que c'est un enjeu qui a été très
important dans la campagne dans les
résultats qu'on voit aujourd'hui rover
oui moi aussi je partage l'opinion
carrelage parce qu'un anxiété qui est
évidente et surtout est calé bouayt la
reprise on sait qu'il n'ya pas eu de
vote final sur le plan de reprise de
monsieur propre alors évidemment ça crée
de l'inquiétude
je pense que c'est là les démocrates qui
ont par porter le fardeau de cette
situation là est-ce que vous est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui pour dire
qu'une anxiété économique aussi robert
qui présente au québec
moi je la sens porte
il faut comprendre que c'est limité à
certains secteurs sont pro bahn à l on
va parler de l'arrêt au nautic on va
parler des restera le tourisme
l'hôtellerie
ça c'est évident qu'un anxiété il faut
se rappeler que le taux de chômage est
quand même à 7 points 5 % arnaud vécu
longtemps à 7.5 pour ça il y avait pas
tant de panique que ça évidemment en
mars on était à quatre points 24.3
c'était assez unique
mais je pense que si on continue à
supporter nos entreprises qui sont
affectés et qui sont obligés de fermer
parce que ça va diminuer l'accès
car là vous en pensez quoi est-ce qu'à
une anxiété comme ça économique chez les
travailleurs il ya surtout une
incertitude on voit pas le bout de cette
crise de cette pandémie
donc je pense que oui elle existe elle
est bien réelle au québec surtout dans
certaines industries on part de
l'industrie du tourisme la restauration
de la culture moi je pense que oui elle
existe elle est là
la présente loi peu importe le président
françois legault a dit aujourd'hui il
faut travailler davantage avec les états
américains pour exporter plus inverse
vers les états unis il a parlé du nord
est américain du texas également robert
de tonnes est ce que vous appuyez ça
absolument je pense que c'est une terre
très propice pour nos manufacturiers
québécois aux fabriques un autre appli
que les neuf et taulé plus près de la
frontière du québec
c'est quand même 15 millions d'habitants
si on fait le mieux d'atlantique là on
se rend jusqu'à la virginie c'est un
autre 55 millions d'habitants alors dans
cette portion la des états unis le quai
port un territoire aussi grand que
l'ensemble ces deux fois la population
canadienne et je me rappelle mon avait
fait beaucoup d'études temps
consommateurs qui ressemble beaucoup aux
consommateurs d'ici a donc je pense que
c'est vraiment ailleurs d'air important
pour nous l'eau pour notre développement
mais est-ce que c'est cohérent de
dénoncé le protectionnisme américain
mais de favoriser d'un autre côté une
forme de nationalisme économique l'achat
local
la souveraineté alimentaire ces messages
là car là mais moi ce que je trouve en
vue alors dans cette position-là donc
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord que
pour notre économie le l'exportation est
crucial c'est un essai un fossé
important pour nous entrepreneurs nos
entreprises notre économie mais en même
temps on a vu monsieur legault cet été
paris beaucoup de nationalisme
économique beaucoup de protectionnisme
et moi je pense que c'est un peu aussi
donnant-donnant dans cet échange n'a
donc pas vouloir être protectionnisme et
en même temps dire qu'on veut exporter
plus donc il va falloir que cette
relation là soit beaucoup plus clair en
fait ça va être quoi le message dominant
est ce qu on veut être nationaliste ou
est ce qu'on préfère l'éviter change
bref vous en pensez quoi robert mémoire
pense que lorsqu'on discute de
nationalisme c'est surtout la protection
de nos sièges sociaux dont fait
référence
et ça c'est une préoccupation que la
majorité des québécois en ont vu que des
centres de décision demeure et si hockey
au québec et même au canada donc parce
qu'on est si le gouvernement un jour un
des gouvernements le vul les deux
derniers les deux précédents pas eu le
courage de le faire ça va un
gouvernement qui nous protégeait aussi
nocif sociaux
ça règlerait beaucoup cette situation-là
donc entre les deux puis évidemment on
peut faire donc le nationalisme
économique de françois legault ce n'est
pas du protectionnisme pour vous je
pense que c'est c'est le protectionnisme
écoutez je pense qu'on a on a besoin de
gens qui vont venir apporter leurs
produits chez nous on peut pas s'auto
suffire vraiment il ya des secteurs sur
laquelle la pandémie a relevé laurent de
l'agro alimentaire par exemple certains
produits médicaux mais dans l'ensemble
je pense qu'on est capable de bien
vouloir qu'on le fait depuis déjà
condamné mais il faut encourager est
important c'est d'encourager nos
entreprises québécoises aux
entrepreneurs aller aux états unis ou à
l'international
c'est une priorité car là est ce que on
regarde ce qui se passe là où aux états
unis avec avec les contestations du
prise d'empreintes
il ya toujours pas de vainqueur nommé ya
des tensions de plus en plus grande
qu'ils grandissent là quelles sont vos
impressions sur ce qui se passe
actuellement
depuis mardi je dors très mal vraiment
là c'est je pense qu'on est tous sur le
qui vive un peu on attend tous l'issue
de cette élection
ce qui me fait peur c'est vraiment le
discours de chambre qui accuse vraiment
ses troupes
on parle de y parle de fraude des
fraudes penser qu'ils sont pas réels
nécessairement parce qu'il ya des
recherches qui ont été faites pour
montrer que en 14 ans il n'a pas eu de
fraude électorale aux états unis donc
mais ces discours là continuent à créer
ce fossé la de plus en plus et moi j'ai
peur que peu importe l'issue mais en
fait si beau hayden finit par soutirer
des états qui lui faut pour gagner
l'élection
j'ai l'impression que oui tshomba
contestée de toute façon mais ça va
vraiment crier ça va vraiment créer une
division puis j'ai peur des
répercussions au niveau social
ce qui ce qui pourrait se passer pour
ensuite à suite à l'annoncé de qui sera
vainqueur
robert e je suis d'accord de carlos ou
les applications sociales
il faut l école économiquement le ce que
je connais des milieux boursiers là
parce que on est une entreprise publique
on a rencontré beaucoup les milieux
financiers pendant dix ans ils n'aiment
pas l'incertitude donc la situation
actuelle c'est sûr que ça les salaires
et conforte de porc il ya des signes
positifs au moins il ya trois tribunaux
quelle mais surtout de trempettes appel
puis ça n'a pas fonctionné
il faudrait que les marchés financiers
un moody's l'agencé de notation notait
cette semaine que le plan de relance de
messieurs byden était supérieur à celui
de monsieur trouvera ses 18 millions de
créations d'emplois comparativement à 11
millions portera la tenue du marché
boursier actuellement la aux marchés
boursiers
ça veut dire que les gens ont quand même
une certaine confiance puisque des
marchés financiers aurait pas vu un côté
positif à monsieur bailon contenu de son
plan de relance
oui et je vais revenir à françois
legault pour terminer notre ca
d'aujourd'hui il ne veut pas pour
l'instant du moins aller de l'avant avec
les changements qui sont proposés par la
santé publique de montréal on parle de
rouvrir les restaurants les salles de
spectacle et j'ai menées et les musées
par exemple qui a raison selon vous car
là est ce que c'est la santé publique de
montréal qui dit essentiellement
attention il faut quand même dégagé un
peu où c'est le premier ministre qui
affirme ben non on ne peut pas faire
d'assouplissement ces pôles tas qui a
raison qui a tort je ne sais pas en fait
c'est vraiment difficile parce que on a
dit on a des chiffres différents on a
des lectures différent de la situation
le plan proposé par la docteure de loin
clairement c'est un plan pour essayer
d'atténuer les dommages sur au niveau
mental au niveau de psychologique des
gens des montréalais donc je pense que
c'est pas nécessairement la même échelle
en fait de comparaison mais une chose
est certaine c'est qu'il faut avoir de
la cohérence moi j'ai de la difficulté à
me rendre au centre eaton aujourd'hui et
voir les magasins bondés et je me
demande comment ça se fait que des
centres commerciaux sont bondés
à côté on dirait des restaurateurs qui
serait capable de mettre toutes les
mesures possibles pour essayer
d'atténuer la propagation du virus
on leur dit de rester fermés oui moi
c'est un corps et c'était cohérent cela
me fait me fait me questionner sur les
raisons réelles puis j'aimerais ça qui
plus de transparence pour qu'on essaie
de nous expliquer pourquoi on prend ses
décisions de robert en terminant moi
j'ai trouvé que ça de son action
politique on sait que les relations
entre la ville de montréal et le
gouvernement sont pas très bonnes
j'ai payé dans le cas de madame bruit je
comprends ses objectifs je suis à
d'accord avec les objectifs
sauf que quand on parle de rouvrir les
salles de spectacle avec 25 personnes
un peu comme di carlo là il ya plus que
de 25 personnes dans des centres
commerciaux
je trouve ça un petit peu il n'y a pas
deux il ya pas de salle de spectacle qui
va fonctionner avec 25 25 personnes par
soir les rassemblements familiaux
on se rappelle qu'en septembre c'est là
où il avait vu ça va recommencer la
deuxième vague
alors je pense que ce que c'est une
guerre politique que l'on gagne vraiment
avec passion veut prévenir le pas merci
de cette analyse
encore cette semaine robert ricard n'a à
la semaine prochaine à la semaine
prochaine